Varys: Though House Durrandon titled themselves
"Storm Kings," they were little more than
gusts.
Their kingdom in the Stormlands had been doddering
to its end for the past few centuries, helped
along by other houses.
Most of all by House Hoare, who were nearly
finished with a monstrous castle at Harrenhal,
too large and too costly a seat to rule only
the Riverlands.
King Argilac knew where the Ironborn would
soon turn.
You'd think a king who wanted to keep his
crown would be wary of a man with fire-breathing
monsters, but King ArgilacDurrandon wasn't
called "the Arrogant" for nothing.
Determined to arrest decline, he sent an envoy
to Dragonstone to enlist Aegon Targaryen and
his dragons against his enemies.
In exchange, Argilac offered lands he didn't
have, and a wife Aegon didn't need.
For as the Valyrians did, Aegon had wed his
elder sister Visenya.
Then as the Valyrians didn't, he took the
younger Rhaenys as well.
Two sisters, two wives.
Perhaps that's why he was so keen to get off
Dragonstone.
Aegon countered Argilac with courtesy.
He sent his own envoy requesting that Princess
Durrandon's hand be given instead to Aegon's
closest friend and rumored half-brother, Orys
Baratheon.
Argilac answered with a box and a note: "These
are the only hands your bastard shall have
of me."
Inside the box were the hands of Aegon's envoy.
How long had Aegon been waiting for such a
pretext?
As his army prepared to sail, ravens flew
to every great lord of the Seven Kingdoms.
All bore the same message: From this day forth,
there would be but one king in Westeros.
Those who bent the knee to Aegon of House
Targaryen would keep their lands and titles.
Those who took up arms against him would be
thrown down, humbled and destroyed.
Poor old Argilac.
He couldn't even match Aegon in arrogance.
Varys: While Aegon marched on Harrenhal after
his coronation, Orys Baratheon had taken most
of his forces, and his queen Rhaenys with
her dragon, south to deal with the excuse
for the invasion: Argilac the Arrogant, King
of the Stormlands.
Argilac had his seat at Storm's End, a castle
considered the most impregnable in Westeros
after Harrenhal.
Argilac may have been arrogant, but he wasn't
stupid or a coward.
His lords advised him to shut his gates and
wait out the siege, but he'd heard what had
happened at Harrenhal and refused to die a
suckling pig cooked in his own castle.
He would meet victory or defeat the same way,
with sword in hand.
He called his banners and marched to meet
Orys Baratheon in the field.
Thanks to Rhaenys' dragon, Meraxes, Orys knew
Argilac was coming, how many men he had, and
how fast he marched.
So Orys simply seized the high ground and
dug in on the hills to wait for Argilac.
As the two armies approached, the wind rose
to meet them, and the rain poured from the
sky, a gale which would give the battle its
name: the Last Storm.
King Argilac's lords urged him to wait for
the weather to die down, but the Storm King
saw that the rain was blowing into the faces
of the Baratheon men on their hills and Argilac
outnumbered the Baratheon host two to one,
with four times as many knights and heavy
horse.
Argilac attacked.
Three times Argilac led his knights against
the Baratheon line, but the hills were steep,
and the rain had beat the earth mud.
The warhorses foundered and slipped, and the
chargers collapsed.
The battle seemed lost until Argilac ordered
the spearmen up the hill.
Blinded by the rain, the Baratheons didn't
see them until it was too late.
One hill fell, then another and another until
only one remained in the Baratheon center.
If Argilac could break through there, he could
split the invading army and flank both halves.
Argilac and his men charged, and the Baratheon
line broke, revealing Queen Rhaenys and Meraxes.
Argilac's vanguard burst into flame, and his
men panicked.
The victory charge fell into chaos, and Argilac
himself was thrown from his horse.
But he didn't yield.
When Orys Baratheon arrived, he found the
old king holding off half-a-dozen men, another
half-dozen dead at his feet.
Orys dismounted to meet the king on equal
footing and offered Argilac one final chance
to yield.
Argilac cursed him instead.
As the storm raged around them, the grizzled
old warrior and the bearded upstart fought
for life and kingdom.
In the end, Argilac got his wish.
He died, sword in hand.
As word of Argilac's death spread, his lords
and knights threw down their swords and fled.
Orys and his vanguard rode to Storm's End
to claim Argilac's castle for Aegon, only
to find the gates barred and the walls manned.
Argilac's daughter had assumed his crown,
and the new Storm Queen was as fond of yielding
as her father.
She declared that Orys would win only bones,
blood, and ashes here.
But her men were weaker than her, and that
night Orys found Argilac's daughter delivered,
gagged, chained, and naked to his camp.
Argilac had refused to give Orys her hand.
Now, Orys could have any part of her he wished.
But Orys unchained the girl, wrapped his cloak
around her, and poured her a glass of wine.
He told her he would take the arms, banner,
and words of House Durrandon to honor her
father's courage in the Last Storm.
Conveniently, Orys had none of his own to
discard first.
The crowned stag became the sigil of House
Baratheon, and Storm's End their seat.
Argilac's daughter would even remain in her
home, though, as a lady instead of a princess.
The Stormlands were now Aegon's, and as tribute,
Aegon demanded the swords of the men Orys
had defeated.
For what purpose, Orys didn't know.
Stannis Baratheon: My brother, Robert Baratheon,
had raised the banners of Storm's End, our
ancestral castle, against the Mad King Aerys.
Jon Arryn of the Vale and Eddard Stark of
the North stood with him, and Hoster Tully
of the Riverlands would join.
But their lands were far from ours and separated
by the combined strength of the West, the
Reach, and King's Landing itself.
Even Robert's own lords were against him.
It was the hardest choice I've ever made:
my brother or my king, blood or honor.
Aerys ruled by right of all the laws in Westeros.
Everyone knew the price of defiance.
But there are deeper, older laws: the younger
brother bows before the elder.
I followed Robert.
Early in the war, Mace Tyrell's indecisive
victory at Ashford cut Robert off from Storm's
End.
Instead of pursuing Robert, and risking his
record, Mace Tyrell turned east and laid siege
to our home.
His vast army and navy encircled us and preventing
any resupply by land or sea.
If a wagon tried to reach us, it was burned.
If a ship tried to land, it was sunk.
We were locked inside Storm's End to starve.
But Robert had commanded me to hold the castle
no matter the cost.
He could ill afford to lose his ancient seat,
which had never fallen.
While Robert smashed Rhaegar on the Trident,
my men ate the dogs because the horses had
already been devoured.
While the Lannisters sacked King's Landing,
we ate the rats.
If the smuggler Davos had not slipped through
the Tyrell blockade with his onions, we'd
have eaten our own dead.
But I held the castle until Lord Eddard remembered
us, and marched to lift the siege.
The Tyrells didn't even put up a fight, and
Robert threw a feast to celebrate Lord Eddard's
"victory."
I was sent to the royal island stronghold
of Dragonstone to deal with Viserys and Daenerys,
the last surviving Targaryen children.
Before I arrived, however, they had escaped
across the Narrow Sea.
Robert was furious.
He stripped me of Storm's End and gave it
to that prancing fool Renly, my younger brother.
I could keep Dragonstone.
The Baratheons say, "Ours is the Fury."
I will show them fury burns.
Robert Baratheon: For our rebellion to succeed,
King's Landing had to be taken, forcefully.
No one was foolish enough to believe that
Aerys was gonna hand his crown over peacefully.
The Mad King's reign needed to end.
What Tywin Lannister's forces did was unfortunate,
but it was necessary to secure the Iron Throne,
and bring peace and justice to the Seven Kingdoms.
My glorious victory at the Trident left me
wounded, but I sent my personal maester to
attend to Ser Barristan Selmy instead; his
wounds were more severe.
Even though Ser Barristan was a member of
Aerys's Kingsguard and fought on the opposing
side, that man's bravery and loyalty were
something to behold.
But this meant my wounds would take longer
to heal and I couldn't ride to King's Landing
myself.
I sent the one man I trusted over anyone else
in this world, Ned Stark, in my place.
Had I been able to ride, perhaps I could have
reached King's Landing sooner and prevented
some of the violence that occurred when the
Lannisters entered the city.
Still, what Lord Tywin did was for the greater
good.
Even what happened to Princess Elia and her
children.
Babies or no, theirs was the same cursed blood
that flowed within the Mad King's veins.
They were dragonspawn and couldn't be allowed
to survive.
What would they grow to be?
Loyal subjects?
Ned, with his damn northern honor.
He and I had our first major fight over the
deaths of the Targaryen children.
Ned called it murder.
Murder!?
It was war!...
It was war...
Lord Stark demanded that the Lannisters be
held responsible for their crimes.
Was it a crime to put an end to a family of
lunatics born of incest?
I wouldn't - and still won't - blame Tywin.
Instead, I sent Ned Stark south to finish
off the remaining Targaryen loyalists.